CHIEF CHARLES RAMSEY, THANK YOU.
>>> RUSSIA RETALIATES AND
UKRAINIAN CIVILIANS DIE.
OVERNIGHT RUSSIAN MISSILES RAIN
DOWN ON A RESIDENTIAL AREA OF
ZAPORIZHZHIA IN SOUTHEASTERN
UKRAINE.
AT LEAST 13 PEOPLE ARE DEAD,
DOZENS ARE HOSPITALIZED.
AND MO VICTIMS, THE RUSSIAN
ATTACK COME JUST HOURS AFTER AN
APPARENT TRUCK BOMB HEAVILY
DAMAGED THEC BRIDGE.
SO THAT CREATES A HUGE
BOTTLENECK.
>> FOR THE VERY LATEST, LET'S GO
TO NICK PATON WALSH.
NICK?
CLEAR THAT HE HEAD -- AFTER A
MEETING WITH THE HEAD OF HIS
INVESTIGATIVE COMMITTEE.
THAT WOULD POTENTIAL INVOKE
DIFFERENT RESPONSES.
WHERE IT'S LIKELY THEY'LL HAVE
TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE.
THESE HAPPEN WEEKLY, BUT THERE'S
GREAT EMPHASIS ON THIS
PARTICULAR ONE.
A KREMLIN SPOKESPERSON CALLED IT
INAPPROPRIATE.
WE SIMPLY DON'T KNOW HOW RUSSIA
IS GOING TO RESPOND, BUT TODAY
STATE MEDIA IS TRYING TO MAKE
LIGHT OF THE DAMAGE, SAYING THAT
CARS ARE MOVING AGAIN ON THE
CARRY WAYS AREAS WHICH THEY'RE
STILL OPENING.
THAT BRIDGE HOG USED AS SUPPLY
TROOPS.
THE IDEA OF A RUSSIAN
RETALIATION DIFFERENT TO
UNDERSTAND.
SLAMMING INTO RESIDENTIAL AREA,
AT LEAST 13 DEAD, 80 INJURED,
HUNDREDS OF RESCUERS TRYING TO
SAVE PEOPLE, AN ORDINARY SCENE
TRAGICALLY BECAUSE OF RUSSIAN
INDISCRIMINATE TARGETING.
DO WE SEE MORE IN THE DAYS
AHEAD?
UKRAINE HASN'T CLAIM IT
OFFICIALLY.
BUT IT'S ANOTHER SIGN OF HOW
RUSSIA'S MILITARY IS FAILING,
AND MANY ARE WONDERING WHAT
COMES NEXT OUT OF MOSCOW.
SO THERE'S A LOT TO UNFOLD HERE.
WITH THAT A WILLIAM TAYLOR.
SO THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT IS
CALLING THIS ATTACK ON THE
BRIDGE A TERRORIST ATTACK.
PUTIN WILL MEET WITH HIS
SECURITY COUNCIL TOMORROW.
WHAT ARE YOUR CONCERNS TONIGHT
ABOUT WHAT MAY FOLLOW?
>> BUT AS NICK SAID, PAM, IT'S
HARD TO TELL.
THE RUSSIANS HAVE BEEN FIRING AT
CIVIL USAGE TARGETS ALL THE
TIME.
NOT CLEAR.
WE KNOW WHERE THE TERRORISM IS
COMING FROM.
IT'S COMING FROM THE RUSSIANS
YOU HAVE THE TACKED CAL AND
SCLOJ OCCASION ATTACK.
WHAT DO YOU EXPECT HIM TO DO IN
RESPONSIBILITY.
IT MIGHT BE FURTHER OUT OF REAR,
BUT YOU'RE RIGHT, HE'S GOT THE
PROBLEM.
HE'S FAILING FORM HE'S FAILING
TO PROTECT INFRASTRUCTURE LIKE
THE BRIDGE.
HE'S FAILING TO GET MORE TROOPS.
HE'S TRYING TO RAISE 34
HUNDRED,000 NEW RECRUITS, AND
PEOPLE ARE LEAVING.
SO HE'S GOT A REALLY -- HE
DOESN'T HAVE THE FRIENDS HE
THOUGHT HE HAD S THE CHINESE AND
INDIANS ARE NOT SUPPORTING HIM.
HE'S GROUT PROBLEMS ON HIS
RIGHT.
THE NATIONALISTS ARE VERY VOCAL.
HE HAS PROBLEMS IN THE STREETS.
THE FAMILIES ARE NOT EAGER TO
SEE THEIR SONS GO OFF TO A WAR
THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND, SO HE'S
GOT BIG PROBLEMS.
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S CONCERN, HIS
WORDS, THAT PUTIN COULD BECOME
DESPERATE.
HE WAS THE ONE THAT BROUGHT UP
THIS IDEA, THE WARNING OF A
NUCLEAR ARMAGEDDON.
THE WHITE HOUSE HAS BEEN WALKING
THAT BACK, SAYING THERE'S NO NEW
INTELLIGENCE TO SUPPORT THAT.
THAT IT WASN'T BASED ON ANYTHING
NEW, BUT DOES HIS GRIM
ASSESSMENT MAKE DIPLOMACY MORE
DIFFICULT, IN YOUR VIEW?
>> YES, AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN
HAVE THIS CONVERSATION WHENEVER
A DIB TATOR THREATENS TO USE
THEM AGAINST ANYONE, WHETHER
IT'S UKRAINIANS OR OTHERS, YOU
HAVE TO TAKE IT SERIOUSLY.
THAT'S A LEGITIMATE
CONVERSATION.
HOW ARE HE'S NOT LOOKING FOR A
WAY TO SOLVE THIS?
THAT WOULD STOP THE WA